do you think you're a better writer when
you're going through happy times in your
life or when maybe things are a little
bit uncertain and you think that's when
you're more creative I think you're
always kind of the same writer no matter
what mood you're in
but what you're writing about changes
and I think you know everything we write
says something about something right and
whether it says something about the
human condition or the world and if I'm
in happier times if I'm in better moods
I'm probably writing something that is
more specifically positive or
celebrating the good things about
humanity but if I'm in a darker place if
I'm sad or if I'm upset I'm probably
writing something that is more a biting
satire of the bad parts of the human
condition but probably the writing
levels are the same like I don't think
me being you know me being in a bad
place or something makes me a better
writer and I definitely don't think you
know artists don't need to suffer in
order to make good art you know but I
think what you are making art about
definitely probably changes and
depending on what you're experiencing at
any given moment
you